hey hun remember at the beginning of the
year when I said I was gonna try to see
as many films as I could regardless of
how crappy they looked yeah can you go
back in time and kill me
Nine Lives is directed by Barry Sanne
Feld and stars Kevin Spacey and Jennifer
Garner and is about a businessman who
really doesn't have much time for his
family he's in the middle of a gigantic
business deal
his company is trying to build the
tallest skyscraper in the United States
and there's also a company in Chicago
that he's competing with and a really
neck and neck so because of this he has
no time for his very young wife played
by Jennifer Gardner or their daughter
and she really wants a cat for her
birthday so he decides whatever I'll get
her a cat I hate cats I don't want cats
he goes to a cat shop run by none other
than Christopher Walken and gets her a
cat but during a freak electrical storm
the cat and Kevin Spacey's switch bodies
and Kevin Spacey is now laid up in a
hospital and as a cat he must try to
convince his family that he is still a
good father look I'm gonna be honest
with you guys when I saw the trailer for
this movie a few months back I genuinely
thought it was a joke I honestly thought
it was a Funny or Die trailer or that it
was not going to be real but this is a
real movie directed by the guy who made
all the men in black movies that's right
it is in theaters now and it stars Kevin
Spacey and you can see it and I did and
holy shit it is just as bad as you
thought it was going to be I am well
aware of the fact that it is super easy
for me to look at a movie like this say
that's horrible go into it expecting
that's going to be horrible and then
come here and tell you that it's
horrible because everyone else is saying
that it's horrible so I feel comfortable
and saying that it's horrible guys what
I'm about to say is not just because I'm
on a hate train for this movie that
everyone else is on it is true this is
an atrocious piece of garbage this movie
should not exist I have no idea why it
does it is clearly a gigantic paycheck
for a lot of people involved I have no
clue why Barry Sonnenfeld took this
project I have no
like Kevin Spacey took this movie isn't
house of cards doing really well for him
I sat through it though and by far the
best part of it was that I also got to
meet a very cool viewer afterwards that
was easily that it made up for
everything that was by far the best part
my biggest problem with this movie is
that it has no idea what its audience is
when you go to a movie that's rated PG
about a talking cat that's trying to
convince his daughter that he's still a
good father you expect it to be for kids
or families right yeah except 75% of
this movie is business meetings and
really really boring stock market
discussions and all kinds of backhanded
business policies and people trying to
become the head of a company and
somebody trying to save said company and
all of this bullshit that has nothing
that a kid would enjoy seeing there were
other kids in this theatre with me to
look bored out of their minds the best
part of this movie is the first 10
seconds where you see some funny cat
videos pulled off a YouTube it's the
best part of the movie everything else
is dog shit there are so many idiotic
things in this film that I took the
liberty of writing them down number one
when they get a cat on the first night
they just let the cat loose in the house
look I have a cat when you buy a cat and
you bring her home she has no idea where
in the hell she is
she needs to be put in one room with her
litter box and her food shown where
these items are and then she can be free
they just let her loose in the house and
they don't even set up a damn litter box
they set up the litter box the following
morning and are actually surprised the
Kevin Spacey as this cat took a piss on
the carpet they don't even put out food
or water for the cat when I take her
home they wait until the next day and
I'm like oh yeah you're a cat you need
to eat right that's right you need food
and water okay I'll give you food and
water and by the way this is where you
shit they put the litter box right next
to her food I mean inches away from her
food what the fuck you don't put the
litter box right by their food cuz when
the cat does this when she's taking a
shit it's gonna get all in her food and
water so fucking stupid what the fuck
happened with this movie I hate it I
hate this movie that's just one logical
problem and this just because I'm a cat
owner and I love cats and what the fuck
I'm actually physically sweating I'm
physically sweating here's an
thing when Kevin Spacey as the cat is
trying to break into his business to try
to stop something from happening there
are two security guards there that
decide it would be really funny to tase
the cat
yeah let's taste the cat and kill it
let's just let's kill this cat
what a great PG family movie let's just
go taze cats my god don't see this movie
it's hot look I'm sorry guys don't see
this movie
it is horrible don't but I have to spoil
shit I have to i cannot go without
spoiling some of the insane stuff that
happens near the end of this movie it
felt like I was witnessing a future the
room or a future Birdemic I am not
joking I was sitting in this theater
thinking this is really happening so
here's the first thing when Kevin
Spacey's son in this movie realizes that
he can't save his father's company from
this evil exec he decides to commit
suicide he wants to jump off of the roof
of the building that they're trying to
build suicide in this kids movie oh
that's not even the best part when he
jumps off he actually does he jumps off
and everyone's like oh my god he's
committing suicide and somehow there's
like immediately a news helicopter
filming it I don't know how Kevin Spacey
as the cat jumps off with him and then
they're like free-falling together and
robbie amell the actor and the cat are
staring at each other in freefall
it's incredible there's nothing like
this movie ever that I've seen it blew
my mind if this movie didn't star Kevin
Spacey and it wasn't directed by Barry
Sonnenfeld and it was directed by Alan
Smithee or some other fake name I would
think this was a purposefully bad movie
like a sharknado but no this is actually
people trying and it is so painfully
unfunny and so horrific ly boring and
completely unaware of its demographic
that I am positive that kids and adults
will leave this movie wanting their
money back never see Nine Lives ever it
does not deserve your money don't even
try to download this thing if you're
into that kind of thing it is not worth
eighty seven minutes of your life that I
wasted I did it so I could talk to you
guys about holy shit
I'll just get what you already know is
coming out of the way I'm gonna give
nine lives and f I really did burn the
ticket by the way I just actually burnt
it in a like a field
it felt so therapeutic you have no idea
well guys that's nine lives you know
what I'm glad I saw it because genuinely
I feel like I could see just about any
movie now I really feel like I could sit
through anything now guys you are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes